Der sechste Spieltag der 2. Bundesliga der Männer ist ausgespielt und wir wollen über die Gewinner und Verlierer des Saisonstarts reden. Was macht Tabellenführer Darmstadt? Daran muss man sich ein bisschen gewöhnen. So gut explodiert Schalke unter Muzlic und was ist jetzt eigentlich schon wieder bei Hertha BSC los? Darüber spreche ich in dieser 2. Liga Sendung mit Kevin Bublitz vom PadaCast und Matthias Kneifl vom Hohen Weit Podcast. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Gilly Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0. Markus Kurt aus dem Bivou.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hach, ich hab das Intro vermisst. Und ich, das ist Marc Schwitzki an der Stelle. Ich führe heute wieder durch diese– was heißt wieder? endlich wieder durch diese Zweitligasendung des Rasenfunk. Ich bin freier Journalist. Ihr lest mich meistens beim RBB und hört mich bei Hertha Bays. Und nachdem Eva dankenswerterweise die letzten zwei Folgen gemacht hatte dieser schönen Zweitigasendung und ich zwischenzeitlich im Urlaub war, bin ich wieder da und top motiviert bis in die Haarspitzen. Aber nicht nur ich, zum anderen ist auch dabei Pada Born-Fan, Host des PadaCast und selbsternannter Prophet Kevin Bublitz. Ich grüße dich.
Deswegen. Sie schlagen sich aber auch unter Wert, finde ich. Sie haben schon Spieler, die einen Unterschied machen können, finde ich. Mit Al Holmström finde ich es schon auch im Sturm jemand, da der schon auch stark ist im Mittelfeld. Lassen wir überleben. Ich weiß nie, wie man auch spricht. Luca Hüre, Leinen, den Finn.
Hüre, Leinen.
Hüre, Leinen. So. Oder Grieb. Das sind schon Spieler. Weiß ich nicht. Ich hätte diesen Verein mit dem Potenzial eher im Mittelfeld, wie gesagt, erwartet. Nicht mehr oben im Kampf drin. So ein bisschen Konsolidierung ist ja schon beifallend. Der Abgang von Kars ist natürlich brutal. Einfach zwei Tore in drei Spielen. Dann geht der nach St. Pauli. Das ist einfach übel. Deswegen muss ich so deutlich sagen, hasse ich diese Transferphase, dass sie länger geht, als die Saison statt schon ist. Ich finde, das ist ein Unding. Gerade für so einen Verein, der auch nicht unendlich Möglichkeiten hat.
Das trifft am ehesten immer die schlechteren, kleineren Vereine, weil die nicht so nachlegen können.
Einen guten Stürmer findest du halt auch nicht einfach mal dann noch so kurzfristig. Das tut Magdeburg schon enorm weh. Thomas hatte zwar zuerst ein bisschen so letztens die Hoffnung, dass das nicht so schwer ins Gewicht fällt. Weil, wie du sagst, Magdeburg ja auch teilweise ansehnliche Spielpassagen hat und das liegt dann meistens an diesem einen oder zweiten, dritten blöden Fehler, wo man sich gleich auch das Ding fängt. Aber das macht schon auch viel aus. Das ist echt, echt bitter. Ich hoffe, dass sie die Ruhe haben und das auch jetzt irgendwie mit einem schmutzigen Sieg, wie man es immer so schön sagt, oder auch mit einem euphorischen Sieg umwünschen können, weil ich finde, der FCM hat sich schon eigentlich in den letzten Jahren gut etabliert. Und ich finde es auch, unabhängig von aller Leistungsgerechtigkeit oder irgendwas, fand es toll, dass sich ein ostdeutscher Verein auch so etabliert hat. Ich bin da gerade ein bisschen enttäuscht, einfach weil ich finde das echt schade, weil das Umfeld, die Stimmung dort im Starten ist überragend. Ich glaube, die kann halt auch– das Thema hatten wir vorhin auf Schalke, du hattest gesagt, wenn der Erfolgsdruck da ist, kann das auch ein Druck werden, irgendwo so eine Kulisse zu haben. Aber vielleicht wird es auch das Ding in den nächsten Wochen, um sie wieder da raus zu pushen.
Ich denke, im Moment ist auch das Thema, du sprachst an, was gestern Markus Fiedler nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, mit den individuellen Fehlern. Und Magdeburg hat halt noch kein Spiel gedreht. Also sprich, wenn sie in den Rückstand geraten, ist das Kind eigentlich schon fast in den Brunnen gefallen. Und wahrscheinlich weiß jeder, der Magdeburg anhängt oder auf dem Platz steht. Oh man, jetzt geht die Scheiße schon wieder los. Auf gut Deutsch. Also sprich, ein 0 zu 1 ist, glaube ich, im Moment psychologisch wirklich schwer für die wegzustecken. Und ich bin gespannt, wie das in dem Konstrukt mit dem neuen Coach dann auch funktioniert. Also ist er im Stande, hier dem Team die Sicherheit zu geben, dass das Team Lösungen findet und sich aus diesem Schlamassel rausarbeiten kann. Oder ist er unter Umständen dann das schweste Glied in der Kette und wird irgendwann mal dann halt vor die Tür gesetzt, ohne ihm jetzt irgendwas an der Misere zuschreiben zu wollen. Aber natürlich wissen wir um die Verdienste von Tietz in dem Umfeld. Und jetzt ist ein neuer Coach und das läuft nicht. Also 1 zu 1 zusammenzählen, irgendwann wird so eine Debatte dann hochkochen. Deshalb ja, keine allzu gute Situation und um noch ein Gedanken zu dem längeren Transferfenster anzubringen. Also da bist du nicht allein. Kevin mit der Meinung auch, Paul Ferny von Lilian als sportlicher Leiter hatte zu mir schon im Juli gesagt, für ihn ist es ein Unding. Also er würde sagen, mit dem Anpfiff der 2. Liga oder jeglicher Liga ist das Transferfenster zu. Weil er hatte damals auch schon gesagt, normalerweise fangen dann gerade finanzkräftige Teams nochmal an, einen Stürmer zu suchen und so ist es ja. Stürmer sind einfach ein begehrtes Gut. Und wer einem eine zweistellige Anzahl von Toren garantiert, der ist schon mal fein raus. Und insofern hat jetzt Magdeburg an der Stelle leider das Nachsehen gehabt und konnte auch nicht mehr wirklich nachlegen. Also deshalb müssen sie jetzt mit dem Personal, das sie haben, erst mal zurechtkommen und ich glaube, da ist einfach im Moment auch zwischen den Ohren ziemlich viel am Struggeln und ich bin gespannt, wie sich das Team dann fängt oder festigt.
Man könnte meinen, sie hätten jetzt eine Chance. Sie fahren jetzt nach Karlsruhe, die heute auch eine Packung bekommen haben.
Aber sind aber gleichzeitig richtig heimstark.
Jaja, klar. Also das ist ungefestigtes Team, was, ja, mal gucken. Aber vielleicht ist das so das Ding auswärts, das zu ziehen. Also mit fünf Niederlagen, ich meine, Bochum hat es eher genauso hart zum Start erwischt.
Es fing ja schon am ersten Spielteil an. Wir erinnern uns gegen Braunschweig zu Hause irgendwann sogar in Überzahl und hatten davor schon das Spiel dominiert und verstehen es nicht, den Sack zuzumachen. Wir kriegen dann so einen Distanztreffer.
Es wirkt bislang einfach, als ob sie wenig Zugriff auf Spieler haben. Es ist nie richtig schlecht, aber der finale Zugriff fehlt. Wie gesagt, gespannt kann man sein, wie es dann den KSC läuft. Danach ist es Elbersberg, danach ist es Darmstadt. Also das ist schon knackig, bevor es dann am 10. Spieltag gegen Preußen Münster geht, was wiederum, glaube ich, dann ein sehr entscheidendes Spiel sein könnte. Wir wollen nicht zu weit in die Zukunft gucken, aber so ist das weitere Programm. Ich würde in meiner Liste mal weitergehen. Du hast es schon angesprochen, Kevin. Bei mir ist Fortuna Düsseldorf auch auf der Kippe. Man müsste fast drüber reden, weil heute Klaus Adolfs darin getunen, nach der 0-3-Niederlage, ja, fast schon angezählt hat, muss man sagen. Zitat, der Trainer ist verantwortlich dafür, dass sich das bessert. Und ob die Frage, wie Adolfs plant, sagt er, ich mache das jetzt nicht mit einem Endspiel. Es wäre aber auch nicht glaubwürdig, wenn ich sagen würde, der Trainer ist außerhalb jeder Diskussion. Da kann man reininterpretieren, was man möchte. Klaus Adolfs ist ein alter Hase in dem Geschäft. Der weiß ganz genau, was er mit solchen Worten sagt. Vielleicht ist das aber ein Thema, was man in den nächsten Wochen noch mal dediziert.
Stichwort Länderspielpause.
Stichwort Länderspielpause. Die nächste steht schon in den Startlöchern quasi.
Ich würde mich aber auch wundern, wenn Alofs, wir kennen womöglich noch seine Amtszeit in Bremen, also er ist ja glaube ich jemand, der Kontinuität zu schätzen weiß.
Er hat Tune 2022 selber geholt.
Ja, also er ist für mich nicht verdächtig, aktionistisch aufzutreten. Deshalb würde ich sagen, Tune ist für den Moment sehr gut.
Das glaube ich auch.
Aber Tune versucht es jetzt halt auch schon in der vierten Saison, dritten, vierten. Und man hat die letzten Jahre immer oben dran gekratzt und es nicht geschafft. Jetzt hat man echt herbe Abgänge auch gehabt, die wirklich sehr, sehr wichtig waren. Deswegen hoffe ich auch, so kenne ich Alofs auch, dass man dem Team noch Zeit gibt, einfach sich wieder zu finden. Nur es könnte natürlich passieren, wenn die jetzt vor der Länderspielpause gar nichts mehr wollen. Boah, wird es, glaube ich, echt eng für ihn.
Das ist so. Dann lasst uns aber zu einem anderen Team kommen. Und dann sind wir beim VfL Bochum. Lasst uns nun das Thema aufmachen zu später Stunde. Ich hoffe, wir kriegen das zeitlich einigermaßen gut über die Bühne. Dort hat es einen Knall gegeben, ein Beben, wie man auch immer so schön sagt, ein Personalbeben. Denn vor gut einer Woche hat man sich sowohl von Trainer Dieter Hecking als auch von Sportgeschäftsführer Dirk Dufner getrennt. Das war die Reaktion auf den sehr enttäuschenden Saisonstarten. Auf fünf Spielen hatte man nur drei Punkte, es sah nicht gut aus. Dieter Hecking hatte ja noch in der letzten Saison das Himmelfahrtskommando übernommen, um irgendwie in dieser Klasse zu halten. Auch das gelang nicht. Aber man hatte sich auf so einer Ebene gefunden, dass man dieses Projekt in der zweiten Liga zusammen angehen wollte, hat dann aber gemerkt, eine richtige Dynamik will da nicht aufkommen. Und Dirk Dufner, na ja, wenige Monate im Amt und schon wieder raus. Hertha-Fans können sich das gar nicht erklären. Der hat doch bei Hertha so gut gewirkt. Wie kann denn das bei Bochum jetzt nicht funktioniert haben? Also ich glaube, auch da hat sich vielleicht jemand erst mal ein bisschen final verbrannt. Aber ich glaube, das ist ein eigener Schwerpunkt, den man gefühlt irgendwann aufmachen müsste, wenn man dann auch irgendwann weiß, wo die Reise bei Bochum so ein bisschen hingeht. Dort war es jetzt so, dass David Siebers übernommen hat, intervimsweise. Dort wurde auch schon gesagt, dass er nicht nur das Spiel jetzt gegen Lürnberg bekommt, sondern auch die beiden weiteren Spiele gegen Düsseldorf und Kaiserslautern. Das Spiel gegen Lürnberg, quasi das Krisenduell des Spieltags. Denn auch Lürnberg stand ja vor dem Spiel wirklich nicht gut da. Das hat man verloren und nun ja. Ich finde, die Leistung gegen Lürnberg war abermals eher unterwältigend, wenn man sich so einen Effekt durch den Trainer erhofft, auch wenn die Beteiligten sich an klare Verbesserungen, sie wollen klare Verbesserungen gesehen haben. Und ja, das mag in einzelnen Momenten, pressigen Momenten, in wenigen Phasen irgendwo der Fall gewesen sein. Aber wenn man da Nürnberg im Vergleich sieht, die auch in einer schweren Situation waren, das war die deutlich reifere Spielanlage. Dementsprechend war das schon unterwältigend. Es gibt so viele Bausteine bei Bochum, man könnte wirklich eine ganze Sendung damit füllen. Vor allem offensiv ist Bochum erschreckend schwach. Sechs Tore in sechs Spielen, ein Elfmeter war aber auch dabei. Und ansonsten waren es nur Kontertore. Ja, musst du auch erst mal machen. Aber aus dem Spiel heraus geht bei Bochum eigentlich gar nichts.
Ja, und auch defensiv überhaupt nicht gefestigt. Wenn du mal anguckst, wie viele Abwehrspieler schon auf Einsatzzeiten gekommen sind. Das sind ja, wenn ich es mal eben so schlaue, ich glaube, 10 Spieler, die offiziell als Abwehrspieler nominiert sind beim Kicker im Kader, alle zum Einsatz gekommen. Das zeugt nicht davon, dass eine Abwehr steht, also dass Grundgerüst steht und drum herum, sondern das zeugt davon, dass halt experimentiert wird. Es wird noch gesucht. Man findet einfach nicht diese Konstellation, wie es passen könnte. Das ist ein großes Problem.
Ein Indiz dafür, dass man im Umbruchssommer nach dem Abstieg– und das ist dann immer naturgemäß, da haben wir drüber geredet– dann ist ein Kader auf dem Umbruch bei Bochum. Das war es auch so. Das, was du gerade angesprochen hast, die vielen Spieler zeigt eben, dass man– also für mich– und das ist auch eine Handschrift, wenn man es positiv bezeichnen möchte von Dr. Dufner– der Kader wirkt eher zusammengewürfelt, als nach einem klaren Plan zusammengestellt. Du hast das Gefühl, dass dich überall mal irgendwie bedient wurde. Ach, da ist ein irgendwie interessanter junger Spieler zur Leih, nehmen wir mit. Ach, da ist ein einigermaßen robuster Stürmer aus der Zeit in der französischen Liga. Ja, das funktioniert auch in der Regel.
Du hast im Mittelfeld zwei 19-Jährige, die alle sechs Spiele gemacht haben. Mit einem 30-Jährigen zusammen.
Und das kann funktionieren, wie gesagt, wenn das Gerüst stimmt. Aber das Gerüst musste ja ein Stück weit neu auch aufgebaut werden. Klar, du hast Timo Horn im Tor, der jetzt aber auch nicht seit sechs Jahren die absolute Nummer 1 in Bochum ist. Du hast Kevin Vogt zurückgeholt, der aber auch aus Gründen bei Bochum, bei Bochum bei Union eigentlich keine Rolle mehr gespielt hat. Den merkst du das Alter langsam an. Leute wie Maxi Wittek oder auch Philipp Hoffmann kommen nicht mehr an die Qualitäten alter Tage heran. Also diese Achse, die es geben müsste, die funktioniert nicht. Also am ehesten müsste man da eigentlich Ibrahima Sissoko und Matos Behrow dazuzählen, die im besten Fußballeralter sind, die aber gefühlt eher von dieser Negativwelle mit erwischt wurden, als voranzugehen. Und dadurch ergibt sich ein Mischmasch, wo man Dieter Hecking nicht allein verantwortlich machen darf, wobei es auch immer hieß, Dieter Hecking hat maßgeblich auch am Kader mitgewirkt. Also es war nicht nur Dirk Duffner, der da dran gearbeitet hat. Aber insgesamt passt da extrem wenig ineinander. Trotz aller Verletzungsprobleme, die der hoch im Kader hat und die man ihnen zugestehen muss, ist das in allen Mannschaftsteilen bislang wirklich zu wenig. Und ja, besorgniserregend, das muss man schon so sagen.
Extrem, extrem besorgniserregend. Sie haben hier in Paderborn gespielt, da habe ich, ich war erschrocken. Da war Vogt noch wirklich herausragend defensiv. Sonst hätte es zur Halbzeit, glaube ich, schon zwei, drei Tore mehr für einen SCP haben können. Der hat sich dann, glaube ich, dabei verletzt, musste dann durch die Halbzeit ausgewechselt werden. War bis dahin der Spieler des Spiels für mich. Aber der Elbmann ist 33 und ich bin bei dir. Also es fehlt so das Konzept. Und ich glaube, das ist wirklich auch du hast gesagt, Hacking, Duftner hast mit Hacking jemanden, der ja auch in anderen Teams, in anderen Vereinen schon da den Duftner-Posten quasi gekleidet hat, der einfach auch selbst ein Netzwerk hat an Spielern, die er kennt, an Spielerberatern. Dann hast du einen Duftner, der natürlich aber das selber tut, dann aber darauf achten muss, dass dieser Hacking mitmacht und so. Wobei ich Hacking nicht als unbequem Typen einschätze, aber so allein, diese ganze Mischung in Bochum wirkt natürlich jetzt auch nach so einem Fehlstart. Sonst würden wir vielleicht anders reden, aber beim Transferfenster habe ich es auch schon gesagt. Da hat man viele, viele junge Spieler geholt, was grundsätzlich cool ist, aber man hatte wenige Leitspieler mit viel Erfahrung und auch noch dem Skill, dem nötigen Körnern, die sie noch haben, im Team behalten, sodass sie die jungen Spieler mitziehen können. Da ist ein Gerrit Holtmann vorne drin, aber das war es dann auch.
Ja, also jeder, der das Spiel am Wochenende gegen Nürnberg gesehen hat, ich glaube, wenn du nicht gewusst hättest, wer ist hier das Team mit einem neuen Trainer und wer ist das Team, das mindestens genauso sehr unter Druck steht. Also ich finde, Nürnberg hat mit zunehmendem Spiel aber immer korrigierter gespielt und hat das Heft in die Hand genommen, hat dann lediglich im letzten Drittel, finde ich, oftmals ein bisschen zu wenig Zug zum Tor gezeigt, aber sie haben es dann trotzdem auch geschafft, in Führung zu gehen und hätten sie das Spiel wirklich mit einem Remis bestritten, dann wäre es sehr, sehr bitter gewesen, weil im Endeffekt war Nürnberg sehr viel reifer und überzeugender im Auftritt. Und bei Bochum muss ich mir wirklich Sorgen machen, muss ich sagen. Also das war ein Spiel, das überhaupt keine Aufbruchsstimmung für mich hat aufkommen lassen. Außer Eckballvarianten, bei denen Kevin Vogt mal als Eckballschütze in der Verscheinung getritt, war ja da kaum was Überraschendes dabei. Also es war tatsächlich ein sehr biederer Auftritt, finde ich. Und ihr hattet schon das Transferfenster angesprochen. Also ich hatte da gestern auch noch mal ein bisschen mein Blick schweifen lassen. Bochum hat laut transfermarkt.de tatsächlich nur 550.000 Euro für Leihgebühren oder Ablösesummen ausgegeben. Das ist das wenigste Invest aller Zweitligisten. Und das als Erstliga-Absteiger der vier Jahre, erste Liga und dementsprechend der TV-Gelder in der Hinterhand hat. Und bei den Abgängen wird es fast noch bitterer. Also es haben 13 Zweitligisten es verstanden. Ein oder mehrere Spiele für mindestens 2 Millionen zu veräußern. Und Bochum keinen.
Selbst Tim Oermann ist für 1,9 Millionen Euro zu Bayer Leverkusen gegangen.
Genau. Also das heißt, du hast vier Jahre in der ersten Liga gespielt und schaffst es nicht im Abstiegsfall, deine Kronjubiläen sozusagen noch zu Geld zu machen. Selbst Darnstadt hat es letztes Jahr– und die waren wahrscheinlich mit der schlechteste Absteiger seit langem– hat es letztes Jahr verstanden, zwei Spieler natürlich nach England zu veräußern und da fast sechs Millionen einzunehmen. Also da muss ich mich schon fragen, was da nicht so ganz aufgegangen ist.
Wenn man sich dem Bochum ein bisschen umhört, dann ist, glaube ich, das einfach auch das Ergebnis jahrelanger schlechter Arbeit, trotz einiger Klassenerhalte. Also Bochum ist ja jahrelang in der ersten Liga geblieben und niemand wusste genau, warum. Da waren da so Freak-Relegationen oder sonst was dabei. Irgendwie hat man sich gerettet, aber selbst in der ersten Liga haben ja alle einen Plan bei Bochum vermissen lassen. Man hat sich von ins nächste Jahr gesteppt und das nächste Jahr irgendwie sich da durchgehangelt. Und ich glaube, das ist das Ergebnis schlechter Arbeit. Die Fans in Bochum waren jahrelang überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit den Gremien. Und da hat es ja auch da einen radikalen Umbruch gegeben. Jetzt hast du mit Andreas Lute einen verdienten Bochumer als Vereinspräsidenten, jemand, der sehr viel jünger auch ist, der da vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen das Fenster aufmacht und frische Luft reinlässt. Denn wenn man sich mit Bochum Journalisten oder so auch unterhält, dann merkt man schon, da hat es richtig gemieft bei Bochum in den Gremien. Und da war kein Esprit, keine Vision, kein langfristiges Denken, eher die typischen Grabenkämpfen und Ego-Nummern eines Traditionsvereins, wie man das oft kennt. Und das hat Bochum sportlich jetzt einfach wehgetan und mündet irgendwann darin, wo der VfL jetzt vielleicht angekommen ist. Und jetzt muss man hoffen, dass Lute und Co. früh genug die Handbremse noch gezogen haben, erste Pflaster draufkleben können, denn die Saison läuft, du wirst jetzt schwierig Weichenstellungen betreiben können. Aber das ist jetzt erst mal das Ergebnis, was du hast. Und ich glaube, in diesem Jahr, das ist so ein bisschen wie Schalke, im ersten Jahr nach dem Abschied, das Überlebenskampf. Du musst erst mal diese Klasse halten und dann wirst du gucken, wo du hingehen musst. Und auch das werden wir in diesem Podcast sehr interessiert begleiten.
Matthias, du hast einen sehr interessanten Aspekt gerade nochmal genannt mit den Transfers. Gerrit Holtmann, der jetzt glaube ich Top-Torjäger ist mit zwei Toren, war ja eigentlich schon weg. Der wurde ja offiziell verabschiedet. Das fand ich so krass. Und auf einmal lese ich die Nachricht, Gerrit Holtmann ist jetzt doch in Bochum geblieben. Ich dachte so, was ist denn jetzt da los? Allein so was ist schon so was von skurril. Hat es das schon mal gegeben, dass ein Spieler offiziell verabschiedet wird?
Jetzt gebe ich mal kurz Insights. Als Dirk Dufner bei Hertha Kaderplaner war unter Friedi Bobic, war der letzte Transfertag. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den Javairo Deiruzu noch kennt. Junger Niederländer damals auf dem Flügel bei Hertha, talentierter Spieler, egal, es hat nicht mehr so richtig funktioniert. Und er sollte ausgeliehen werden nach Bordeaux, wenn man sich mit einem anderen Flügelspieler schon sicher einig war. Laut eigener Aussage. Das ist dann aber kurz vor Transferende geplatzt. Und Deiruzun war auch schon auf dem Weg nach Bordeaux und man hat ihn gebeten, ihn noch mal zurück zu holen. Dass er den Flug quasi abbricht und noch mal zurückkommt. Und das ist dann nicht passiert. Und am Ende hatte Hertha keinen Flügelspieler. Also auch das passiert unter Dukdorf, und spricht für eine gewisse Planlosigkeit.
Ja, ich glaube, wir hatten es in Darmstadt auch schon mal, dass Klaus-Glias Sula nach dem Bundesliga-Abschied verabschiedet wurde mit allen anderen Abgängen am letzten Spieltag. Und dann hat man sich in der Sommerpause doch noch mal zusammengefunden. Es war aber schon so ein bisschen absehbar, dass man da das Gespräch noch mal suchen wird. Aber offiziell war er erst mal weg und ist dann doch geblieben. Oder ist noch mal angeheuert. Aber dennoch, Bochum ist für mich tatsächlich so schon erschütternd. Also ich habe auch noch mal ein bisschen nachgelesen. Angeblich, zumindest laut Fadz-Artikel, hat Geschäftsführer Ilya Kenzig gesagt, dass er mit Dieter Hecking einen Meilenstein in der Geschichte des Vereins verpflichtet hätten. Mit seiner Verpflichtung einen Meilenstein in der Geschichte des Vereins, da denke ich mir auch so, boch, das sind ganz schön große Worte. Ja, und wir haben es damals mit einem Erstligisten zu tun, der noch versucht hat, irgendwie die erste Liga zu halten. Aber im Endeffekt, wenn du Max fragen würdest, hat, glaube ich, das Ganze begonnen, in die falsche Richtung zu laufen, als sie Thomas Letsch entlassen hatten. Damals in der Relegationssaison, die dann noch gegen Düsseldorf irgendwie umgebogen wurde. Aber der hatte ja zumindest eine fußballerisch sehr klare Handschrift. Also da war das Ergebnis vielleicht dann gegen Ende der Saison nicht mehr so durchweg richtig, weshalb dann der Verein gedacht hat, okay, wir müssen hier reagieren, um die Klasse zu halten. Aber dennoch war das vielleicht ein bisschen voreilig. Und im Endeffekt ist es tatsächlich für mich nicht klar, wo Bochum jetzt hinsteuert. Und ich weiß nicht, wer von euch vor ein paar Wochen gesehen hat, wie Hermann Gerland im Sportstudio war. Trainer, Co-Trainer von Bayern etc., Jeder wird ihn kennen oder im Gesicht vor Augen haben. Der hat ja selber bei Bochum seine fußballische Sozialisation erfahren. Und der wurde darauf angesprochen, wie er denn die Chancen von Bochum einschätzte. Und der war total pessimistisch und hat gesagt, die Bundesliga-Rückkehr ist nahezu ausgeschlossen. Und zwar nicht nur in dieser Saison, sondern auf Sicht. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, puh, der kennt sicherlich noch ein paar Leute in Bochum und weiß die Situation einzuschätzen. Und der war sehr klar, wie man ihn kennt und sehr negativ. Und wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen hinter diese ganze Doppelentlassung und Hacking guckt und was da alles einfach schon im Argen liegt, dann ist man dazu geneigt zu sagen, ja, da könnte man im Moment mitgehen.
Wie gesagt, jetzt wurden ja zumindest auf Präsidiumsebene und so weiter wichtige Schritte gegangen, um da vielleicht einen Neuanfang zu starten. Aber oft, wie es ist, ist es dann vielleicht schon zu spät oder ähnliches. Das wollen wir noch nicht sagen nach dem sechsten Spieltag. Da sind noch einige Weichen zu stellen.
Das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf am Samstag, dann das Top-Spiel, das wird für beide Teams sehr spannend. Aber für ein VfL-Bohrum ist das, glaube ich, schon… Das wäre der Moment, wo du Momentum kreieren kannst, wenn du das Ding zu Hause gewinnst.
Absolut, absolut. Ich würde sagen, wir schreiten voran und kommen… Auch da würde ich vielleicht aus zeitlichen Gründen den Abbindner zum 1. FC Nürnberg machen, bevor wir zu der RTA BSC kommen, über die ich schon länger reden wollen würde. Denn auch Nürnberg ist so ein bisschen wie im positiven Hannover am Bielefeld. Es wurde schon sehr viel darüber geredet. Und jetzt nach dem Sieg gegen Bochum ist ja auch die Frage, in welche Richtung geht es. Miroslav Klose hat gesagt, ey, wir brauchen einfach nur Zeit. Diese Mannschaft hat gegen Bochum zum zweiten Mal in dieser Form zusammenspielen können. Späte Transfers, Verletzungen und so weiter. Späte Transfers, auch wie Finn-Ole Becker oder Krimal, die schlagen jetzt offensichtlich ein. Ich glaube, dass Nürnberg so eine Black Box noch ist, dass sie vielleicht ein, zwei Spieltage noch abwarten müssen, um wirklich beurteilen zu können, wo die Reise dahin geht. Denn wie gesagt, dieser Kader hat sich spät gefunden. Das ist eine junge Mannschaft mit auch einigen Spielern, die den deutschen Fußball auch noch nicht kennen. Und dieser Sieg hat jetzt zumindest ein bisschen beruhigt. Und deswegen würde ich…
Einen Satz?
Ja, machte meines Amtes sagen, wir schreiten doch ein Team weiter, außer jemand möchte unbedingt noch einen Punkt zu Nürnberg sagen.
Nur einen Satz?
Natürlich. Gerne.
Und zwar hat Miroclose die große Stärke von Grimaldi entdeckt. Du wechselst ihn kurz vor Schluss ein und er macht einen. Immer.
Ja, so einen brauchst du auch im Team.
Das ist unfassbar, der Typ. Ich war echt traurig, als der uns noch verlassen hat. Das ist eine richtige Waffe, wenn du den reinbringst. Das ist wirklich krass. Schade, ganz, ganz komisch.
Genau, also bin ich bei dir. Das war so Klose-Vibes. Du hast einen Kopfballstarken Mittelstürmer, der einfach das Ding reinwuchtet und wahrscheinlich noch den Gegenspieler mit reingewuchtet hätte. So wirkt es in der Situation. Also, ich meine, was hat man von Nürnberg erwartet? Nürnberg hat zwar viele Gelder generiert durch Transfers, aber sie haben ein rund erneuertes Team. Und wie du sagst, Mark, auch ein sehr junges Team. Also, das ist eine wahnsinnige Herausforderung für Miroclose. Und man sieht ihm ja quasi bei jedem Spiel an, was da auch für eine Last auf ihm lastet. Und wie sehr er sich mit dem Club und mit der Mannschaft identifiziert und das zum Erfolg führen will. Und insofern kann man da gestern sagen, Glück auf. Ja, auch wenn es nur der Partnerverein ist oder der befreundete Verein, der das auf seine Fahnen geschrieben hat. Klub auf. Klub auf, genau. Dass das hoffentlich sich verfestigt. Und ich finde, sie haben auch mit Markiev, mit dem Sechser, zumindest gestern einen sehr auffälligen Spieler ins Spiel bringen können. Also auch ein Last-Minute-Transfer. Sechser eben eine sehr neurologische Position für jede Mannschaft. Und ich finde, er hat Struktur, Pass-Sicherheit und Spielverständnis ins Spiel gebracht. Und da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie er sich weiterentwickelt. Aber für den ersten Eindruck, den ich von ihm gewonnen habe, sehr positiv.
Sehr schön. Dann haben wir doch noch kurz über den Club geredet. Wenn ich allein die Abgänge abdurchgehe. Janda, Kastrup, Zimas, Emreli, Antiest. Das ist schon richtig doll. Dazu jetzt irgendwie so jetzt der Abgesang auf Robin Knoche so ein bisschen gestartet, der letztes Jahr noch wichtig war. Also da tut sich viel im Team. Und wo sich auch viel tut, ist mal wieder in der Hauptstadt. Die Überleitung nehme ich doch gerne mit für unseren letzten Verein in dieser Liste. Hertha BSC, ja, es ist so ein Stück weit mein Steckenpferd. Ich hoffe, dass ich nicht zu sehr monologisiere. Man wollte am 6. Spieltag an das 13.0 an den Überraschungserfolg in Hannover anknüpfen und knüpfte dann aber zielsicher an die Auftritte davor an. An die katastrophalen Auftritte davor, muss man sagen. Und verlor letztendlich völlig verdient gegen ein sehr unaufgeregtes SC Paderborn mit 0 zu 2. Und in Berlin, das kann ich sagen, brennt der Baum komplett. Und das betrifft nicht mehr nur Trainer Stefan Leitel, sondern in Kürze, um das abzuwiegen, auch Sportdirektor Benny Weber, der mittlerweile, glaube ich, also dessen Schicksal mittlerweile, glaube ich, an Stefan Leitel angeknüpft ist. Um das wirklich möglichst kurz abzuhandeln, dieser Saisonstart ist eine Katastrophe. Er ist der schlechteste seit Mitte der 80er Jahre. Er hat das in vielen Städten. Es ist keine Ergebniskrise, um das mal vorwegzunehmen. Es ist nicht so, dass die nur nicht die Tore machen oder individuelle Fehler haben, wie es oft auch zum Beispiel unter Vorgänger Christian Fjell der Fall war, sondern es ist eine wirklich spielerische Krise. Er hat das in vielen Statistiken der 2. Liga, teilweise sogar letzter oder nah am letzten Platz, ob das Torgefahr ist, ob das Ballbesitz-Statistiken sind und ähnliches. Man weiß nicht so genau, was in diesem Sommer passiert ist, denn wenn man sich daran zurückerinnert, Stefan Deitel übernahm, klar, es gab so einen Schocker gegen Elbersberg, aber danach hat er diese Mannschaft sehr souverän zum Klassenerhalt geführt, Hertha war zwischenzeitlich 7 Spiele ungeschlagen, aber auch schon zum Ende der Rückrunde hatte ich irgendwie das Gefühl, mir fehlt so der nächste Step, denn eigentlich hatte Hertha nur Ruhe und du hättest eigentlich den nächsten Step taktisch einfach vorbereiten können. Und der blieb so ein Stück weit aus und ich hatte schon da irgendwie das Gefühl, ja ist jetzt alles nicht schlimm, im Sommer kann es aufgearbeitet werden, aber irgendwie wird da was liegen gelassen an Zeit. Und dann kommt Hertha aus der Sommerpause heraus und ist eigentlich einer der Top-Favoriten dieser Liga, allein was das individuelle Potenzial dieser Mannschaft angeht, denn du hast nicht nur Spieler wie Reze und Cuisins gehalten, sondern sogar Spieler wie David Kofnatski dazugewonnen. Ja, Abgänge wie Derry Scherhand oder Ibrahim Masar taten weh, auch John Jo Kenny, aber insgesamt war das auf dem Papier, wenn man das auch einfach mit dem Rest der Liga vergleicht, eine Mannschaft, wo du sagen musst, die muss und den Aufstieg mitspielen. Punkt aus Ende und das war auch das formulierte Saisonziel, da ist Stefan Leithel quasi vorangeschritten und hat das formuliert. Und dann dieser Auftritt auf Schalke, der alles ins Rollen bringt, der desaströs ist und der nicht erkennen lässt, was in diesem Sommer überhaupt getan wurde. Und so zog es sich durch. Ja, man hatte zwei okaye, maximal okaye Auftritte gegen den KSC und gegen Darmstadt. Und dann dieses fast schon Freakspiel, muss man mal sagen, der positive Betriebsunfall gegen Hannover, wo plötzlich Dinge geklickt haben und Hannover selber ja, wo man aber auch sagen musste, keiner hat hochgejubelt, denn dieses 3-0 ist ja auch, sag es Kevin.
In der ersten Halbzeit ja eigentlich zwei Tore machen können, also dann oder müssen, eins auf jeden Fall. Und Hertha hat mit dem 1-0 in Hannover dann quasi, da hat es wirklich Klick gemacht. Und ab dem Moment hat Hannover echt Probleme gehabt, überhaupt noch mal ins Spiel zu finden. Das war so ein Moment, wo das Potenzial aufgeblitzt ist bei der Hertha, weswegen ich sie auch vor der Saison deutlich, deutlich weiter oben gesehen habe. Aber für mich war damals schon, habe ich gezögert, weil Stefan Leitel ist für mich offenbar, hat in Hannover auch schon sehr gestruggelt. Er macht bisher den entscheidenden Schritt mit seinen Teams nicht, nämlich was du gesagt hast, dann, wenn man die Zeit hat, zu gucken, dass man in ein paar Wochen, Monaten wieder den nächsten Schritt macht. Das irgendwie geht es bei ihm ab. Aber ganz großer Punkt, und dann kannst du weiter in dein Monolog machen. Matthias hat das vorhin gesagt, Wohlfühlatmosphäre hat für mich das Gefühl, aber nicht nur, dass es diese Sorte in Berlin bei der Hertha nicht gibt. Das fing an mit den Dadai-Klans und keine Ahnung was, also ohne das jetzt abwertend zu meinen. Aber es war immer Unruhe drin, so wie das auf Schalke in Hamburg auch hattest. Ganz komische Gemengel. Ich kann das gar nicht so richtig beschreiben. Du kannst das viel besser wahrscheinlich fassen, weil du das miterlebst, aber auch von außen gesehen. Es hat Hertha für mich das größte Problem, dass Unruhe-Faktoren da sind im Verein, von außen rein vielleicht auch in der Mannschaft, auch bestimmte Spieler bevorteilt werden. Du hast mit Reze natürlich auch einen star Spieler, einen potenziellen Starspieler, was immer gefährlich ist in so einer Konstellation, wo du den Druck hast, dass alle funktionieren müssen und sich nicht nur auf einen verlassen. Das sind so ganz viele Faktoren, die dann dieses Potenzial vielleicht auch wieder einfach runterdrücken und erdrücken.
So.
Es folgt der Satz, den ich auch schon beim VfL Bochum gesagt habe. Es ist das Ergebnis jahrelanger schlechter Arbeit. Da müssen wir jetzt, klar, wir kennen jetzt gefühlt den Urschleimanfang und Winters und so weiter, aber wenn man sich allein die letzten Jahre anguckt, hat man den Schritt verpasst in der neuen sportlichen Gemengelage mit Geschäftsführung und Sportdirektor Benny Weber, sondern also überall muss eine sportliche Identität stecken und die hat Hertha in den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren nicht entwickelt. Wie möchte Hertha Fußball spielen und wie wählt man danach Trainer und Spieler aus? Das ist nicht passiert. Es wurde von der Berliner Weg ausgerufen, der auch löblich ist und der ja auch viel mit Nachwuchsförderung zu tun hat. Aber wie will man Fußball spielen? Das hat man verpasst und dadurch, also wenn man sich die Trainer anguckt, so Paldardai, Christian Fjeld und Stefan Leithelt, die haben in ihrem Spielansatz nichts miteinander zu tun. Und auch die einzelnen Spieler, du kannst einzelne Spieler rausnehmen und sagen, der gibt ja für sich ja Sinn, das ist eigentlich ein guter Spieler. Aber passt ein Michael Karbovnik als technisch beschlagnener Ballbesitzspieler zu einem Paldardai? Denn in dem Jahr wurde er ja geholt. Nein, passt er nicht. Also ist er links liegen gelassen worden und ist in ein Loch gefallen, aus dem er nie rausgekommen ist. Hat man Christian Fjeld die Zeit gegeben, als junger Trainer, der noch nicht viel Erfahrung im Profibereich hat, erst mal zu wachsen, ohne direkt um den Aufstieg mitspielen zu müssen und demnach einen Kader aufzustellen, der sofort funktionieren müsste? Nee, hat man nicht. Und Christian Fjeld hat schnell Ergebnistruck gespürt und ist von seiner Spielweise irgendwann abgesprungen und man hat nicht mehr erkannt, was da überhaupt auf dem Feld passiert. Stefan Leitel ist ein Trainer, der seine Lieblinge hat. Und das kann denn wie in Fürth funktionieren? Aber wenn du ihm das nicht gibst oder in dem Fall sogar sagst, Stefan Leitel hat sich auf die Dreierkette festgelegt und wir brauchen Schienenspieler, aber man holt keine Schienenspieler, sondern den x-zentralen Mittelfeldspieler, dann braucht man sich auch da nicht, wenn dann die Dinge nicht funktionieren. Also will sagen, es fehlt eine grundsätzliche sportliche Identität, nach der man einen Trainer auswählt und nach dem man dann die Spieler auswählt. Und dadurch passen diese Versatzstücke seit Jahren nicht zusammen. Das verunsichert die Mannschaft immens. Man hat einfach das Gefühl, dass das Team ums Team in den letzten Jahren an Kompetenz verloren hat. Es wurden jetzt wichtige und richtige Schritte vom Präsidium, was ja auch noch nicht lange im Amt ist gegangen. Man hat mit Ralf Huschen, Kevin du kennst ihn bestens aus Paderborn, einen sehr fähigen Geschäftsführer für die Finanzen geholt, der bislang einen sehr guten Eindruck bei Hertha BSC macht in seinem Jahr, dass er jetzt da ist. Und man hat zuletzt mit Dr. Peter Görlich einen neuen Geschäftsführer für unter anderem den sportlichen Bereich geholt, der aber auch Marketing und ähnliches verantworten soll, der sechs Jahre lang sehr gute Arbeit bei Hoffenheim gemacht hat. Das waren die Jahre mit Nagelsmann und Co., wo man Champions League gespielt hat, wo viele gute Entscheidungen getroffen wurden, wo man in Teilen– man muss Hoffenheim und das Projekt und Konstrukt nicht mögen– aber in gewissen Teilen war Hoffenheim regelrecht Marktführer, was Sportwissenschaft angeht, medizinischer Bereich, NLZ und so weiter. Also man hat jetzt fähige Leute, die natürlich aber auf der Geschäftsführungsebene immer eher langfristig wirken, die selten ad hoc etwas entscheiden können, wie der Trainer, was sofort einen Effekt hat und die sich das auch erst mal angucken müssen. Besonders Görlich, der erst seit dem 1. September effektiv im Amt ist. Aber auf ihn werden jetzt, glaube ich, harte Entscheidungen zukommen, weil sie unausweichlich sind. Du merkst, dass Trainer und Mannschaft nicht zusammenfinden. In den Entscheidungen von Stefan Leitel ist wenig Leistungsprinzip und Gespür für die Situation, um Spielsituationen zu merken. Du merkst, dass Benny Weber, ein Satz noch, dass Benny Weber ihm den Rücken stärkt, weil du jetzt auch spürst, dass Benny Weber in den letzten Jahren so viel an Kredit verloren hat, trotz seiner aufopferungsvollen Arbeit und den schwierigen Voraussetzungen, dass man weiß, dass wenn Stefan Leitel geht, wird Benny Weber auch gehen müssen. Deswegen tut Benny Weber einen Teufel und stellt selber die Trainerfrage, sondern bügelt das überhaupt nicht souverän medial ab. Und dementsprechend ist dieses gesamte Umfeld bei RTWC und auch die Verantwortlichen selbst, alles ist gerade panisch. Und deswegen entwickelt sich auch keine Konstanz, und dann fällt vielleicht mal so ein Sieg wie gegen Hannover runter. Aber eine langfristige Entwicklung sehe ich in dieser Konstellation nicht mehr.
Ja, Stefan Leitel verliert sich schon in Plattitüden. Wenn ich mir die Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel jetzt anschaue, ist es für mich und klar, jetzt kann man sagen, was soll er auch sonst sagen. Es ist so dieses typische so, ich kann der Mannschaft keinen Vorwurf machen, finde ich immer. Wenn der Satz kommt, in so einer Tabellensituation weiß ich immer, okay, eigentlich kannst du dich jetzt auch verabschieden. Weil, also ganz ehrlich, die Leistung, du hast ja auch sehr aufgeregt über die Leistung auch zurecht. Das war wirklich krass. Als hätte ich niemals der Härte, ich habe ja vor dem Spiel auch gesagt, dass ich durchaus ein attraktives Spiel erwarte. Weil zwei Teams auf dem Platz sind, die vom Potenzial her offensiv Fußball spielen können. Und das ist halt krass, dass die Härte das gar nicht zeigt.
Weil sie das gefühlt nicht an die Hand bekommen. Stefan Leitel hat bislang, und das ist ja auch der größte Vorwurf aus Hannover, also in Fürth hat er irgendwie den Fürther, genau, in Fürth hat das irgendwie funktioniert, weil da vielleicht die perfekte Mischung seiner Spielertypen da war. Aber in Hannover hat man fehlende spielerische Entwicklung gesehen. Da war Hertha ein reines Umschalt-Team. Und bei Hertha, muss man so sagen, und der Fußball hat gereicht, als Hertha gegen den Abstieg gespielt hat. Da hat es gereicht, Fabian Reese mal tief zu schicken, und der macht die Kugel rein. Jetzt aber wird's so aufsteigen, die anderen Teams wissen das, und du musst jetzt eine Idee mit Ball entwickeln. Und wenn du dann aber weiter mit einer Dreierkette spielst, nicht funktionierenden Flügelspielern, einem Fabian Reese, der im Mittelsturm verhungert, jetzt zuletzt wurde die Viererkette geändert, aber auch einem Toni Leisner in der Abwehr immer wieder das Vertrauen gibt. Der soll den Spielaufbau orchestrieren. Bei allem Respekt vor Toni Leisner. Das geht nicht. Das geht nicht. Und stattdessen werden eher junge Spieler unter den Bus geworfen, was wiederum auch nicht zur Philosophie bei Hertha passt. Und du merkst einfach, es passt nichts ineinander. Und es sind nicht mal diese berühmten Ansätze da, die sich Verantwortliche oft klammern. Die Spiele sehen katastrophal aus. Also fast jedes Spiel in dieser Saison sah aus wie ein letztes Spiel unter einem Trailer.
Sie laufen einem Wunschdenken hinterher einfach. Das ist das Problem. Sie erkennen offenbar nicht oder sie gestehen sich nicht ein, dass sie momentan diesen attraktiven Fußball des favorisierten– ich sag's mal– Ligakrösus vielleicht, ist ja vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so, aber schon jemanden Verein, der mehr Geld hat, dass sie dem nicht gerecht werden können. Und dann kriegen sie es nicht hin, was jetzt zum Beispiel gerade unter Lieberknecht geschieht. Defensiv zumindest, sie nur mal zu rocken und dann halt ein anderes Spiel zu spielen. Das wieder, wie du gesagt hast, zu versuchen, außer Defensive heraus, eine Rese zu schicken.
Weil der Kader aber auch so nicht zusammengestellt ist. Das ist das große Problem. Der Kader ist für offensiven, dominanteren Ballbesitzfußball geplant. Du brauchst mit dem Mika El Cuisans, auch wenn er sich in den letzten Jahren gewandelt hat, er läuft mehr, er kämpft mehr, brauchst du jetzt nicht kämpferischen Umschaltfußball spielen. Mit Kevin Sessa brauchst du das auch nicht machen. Die Spieler sind sichtlich verunsichert von dieser Spielweise. Und das ändert sich wenig. Plötzlich hat man sich die Hoffnung der Fans an den 16-jährigen Kenneth Eichhorn, der das sehr gut macht. Aber dass es überhaupt so weit kommen musste, zeigt ja, wie schlimm es um die eigentlichen Leistungsträger steht. Selbst Fabian Reese, der der oberste Schützling von Stefan Leitel ist, ist nicht wieder zu erkennen.
Hast du 2. Liga aber auch vielleicht nicht verstanden. Das ist keine Treterliga, so wie früher, aber es ist einfach– frag mal in Darmstadt nach– das ist einfach eine Grundvoraussetzung, dass das neben der tollen Stimmung einfach auch in Defensivverbund passt. Das ist jetzt abgedroschen, das klingt abgedroschen, aber die hat er kassiert einfach haarsträumende Gegentore auch. Das aus Spielsituationen heraus, wo das völlig gar keinen Not tut.
Du kannst aktuell jeden Aspekt nehmen.
Das kommt jetzt in die Situation gerade. Also wie haben die das jetzt hingekriegt in diesem Moment?
Durch völlige Verunsicherung.
Auf der anderen Seite kratzten Felix Götze vom… Ich weiß gar nicht, Kufnacki oder wer war es?
Kufnacki.
Kufnacki kratze es von der Linie. Das passiert auf der Gegenseite nicht, wenn der Elze Bilbia da kommt. Der 2. Minute kann Bilbia zwar auch schon das Tor machen, aber dann nachher… Den Spieler haben die in dem Spiel gar nicht im Griff und der war beim SC Kindesau unter dem Ding durchgelaufen. Außer Form, der macht hier zwei Tore und hat noch die Chance für ein drittes. Als wir letztes Heimspiel die Fans gefragt haben, wer war für die der Spieler spielt, haben drei Fans uns am Mikrofon gesagt, frag mal lieber nach dem schlechtesten Spieler des Spiels und auch der Saison bisher. Dann haben wir gesagt, wer ist das? Dann haben sie alle durch die Bank gesagt, Philipp Bilbia. Und der ist der Matchwinner in Berlin.
Und sagt nach dem Spiel, und wie viel Spiegel kannst du der Hertha vorhalten, sagen, ja Berlin als Stadt ist schon schön, aber Fußball spielen will ich hier nicht, ist mir alles ein bisschen zu unruhig. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Matthias, vielleicht noch deine Passenzen zu Hertha, und dann wiegen wir das Ganze mal ab.
Ja, also ihr habt jetzt schon die defensive Anfälligkeit erwähnt, aber wenn man sich jetzt inklusive des Pokals die sieben bisherigen Pflichtspiele anschaut und haben sie halt fünfmal auch gar kein Tor geschossen. Und das ist für einen selbsternannten Ausstiegskandidaten eigentlich ein vernichtendes Zeugnis. Ich fand es vor der Saison gut, dass eine Mannschaft sich da aus der Deckung wagt, aber offenbar war das Feld ja gar nicht dafür bereitet, also dass man sich da wirklich in der Rolle hätte sehen dürfen. Und ich finde auch, dass man der Hertha anmerkt, dass– also du hast alles schon gesagt im Endeffekt– mag aber, dass sie es überhaupt nicht verstehen, dem Spiel ihren Stempel aufzudrücken. Und das bedeutet ja nicht, dass man Ballbesitz wie blöd hat, sondern dass man auch mal versteht, ohne Ballbesitz das Spiel zu dominieren, in Anführungszeichen, oder zumindest im Griff zu haben. Und das fehlt der Hertha meines Erachtens absolut. Und wir hatten auch gerade den Namen Kenneth Eichhorn als The Next Big Thing schon mal fallen lassen. Ja, also auch für ihn alles andere als dankbar, in so einem Moment in dieser Mannschaft wirken zu dürfen oder zu müssen.
Weil man sagen muss, er macht das auch für seine 16 Jahre und sieben Wochen hart und beräumend gut. Also das muss man wirklich sagen.
Und den letzten Aspekt, den ich vielleicht noch ins Spiel bringen würde, auch hier hat Hertha ja gar nicht so viel Geld in die Hand genommen, um sich zu verstärken, aber man hat Geld in die Hand genommen, womöglich, um Rese und Cuisance zu binden. Und dann ist vielleicht die Frage, war das vielleicht der richtige Ansatz? Also man hat in bestehendes Personal investiert, was ja durchaus auch sinnig sein kann, weil man offenbar ja weiß, was die der Mannschaft geben können. Bei Neuzugänge ist das nicht immer gewährleistet. Aber zumindest schien mir das jetzt für den Moment nach dem sechsten Spieltag nicht der allerbeste Weg gewesen zu sein, dass ich hier viel Geld für diese beiden Personalien aufwende. Auf der anderen Seite aber kaum was investiere. Also ich hole einen Morris-Kratten-Macher, klar für eine gewisse Leihgebühr. Oder habt ihr den geliehen?
Nee, der war zum Nullbetrag geliehen, glaube ich.
Ja, okay. Aber es ist dennoch überschaubar. Also so unter das Bild ab.
Ich habe weiterhin krasse wirtschaftliche Zwänge. Das ist definitiv so. Und ja, du hast vollkommen recht. Es ist so, dass man einen Großteil des Budgets, quasi des Etats, dann an Reze und Cuisance, vor allen Dingen aber an Reze, gebunden hat. Und wenn dann aber quasi ein Großteil des Etats mit Cuisance und Reze auch nicht performt, weil du sie nicht in Rollen bekommst, in denen sie performen, naja, dann merkst du dann an anderen Stellen, dass da große Lücken sind. Wie gesagt, man hat mit Dreierkehrt die Saison gegangen, man hat keinen Schienenspieler verpflichtet. Die Schienenspieler sind Deo Seefolg als Rechtsfuß auf links und ein Julian Eitsperger, der tolles Talent ist, der eine gute Laie nach Essen in der Dritte Liga hatte, aber seine erste Zweitligasaison spielt. Und deswegen ist man jetzt auch abgerückt davon, spielt dann aber gegen Paderborn mit Dinos Gächter als Rechtsverteidiger. Das ist ein Experiment, was zur Halbzeit beendet wurde und was auch aussagt, Stefan Leith in dieser Kader, das fühlt sich bis heute fremd an. In vielen. Du kannst ja tausend Personalien durchgehen, das wäre jetzt nicht zielführend, aber du merkst einfach, dass es knirscht, dass diese Mannschaft nicht weiß, was sie auf dem Feld zu tun hat, in wenigen Spielsituationen, dass es sie massiv verunsichert und dass natürlich unter Verunsicherung die individuelle Klasse irgendwann begraben wird.
Vielleicht tue ich ihm auch jetzt Unrecht, aber für mich ist– und ich bin gar kein Fan von Trainerentlassungen– aber das ist für mich das perfekte Beispiel bei Stefan Leithel gerade, wo es meiner Ansicht nach absolut Sinn machen würde, darüber nachzudenken. Das können viele sagen, wenn die das nächste Spiel gewinnen. Ja, klar, siehst du.
Ja, bei dem Punkt ist man hinaus, denn selbst das Spiel gegen Hannover hat man ja 3-0 gewonnen und es hatte gar keinen Effekt auf die Mannschaft.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das, wie du sagst, da passt es nicht einfach. Es passt nicht. Und ich will damit nicht sagen, dass Stefan Leitl das Große nicht kann. Also, das mit der Mannschaft zum Aufstieg zu führen. Also, eine Mannschaft mit Favoritenstellung, so müssen wir es besser formulieren. Es scheint einfach vom Umfeld nicht zu passen, vom Typ her nicht. Er ist natürlich auch ein Typ, so er wickt auf mich immer sehr ruhig und besonnen und…
Er hat teilweise neidisch über Teams wie Elbersberg geredet und immer wieder die Kotsmüge im Verein und die Ruhe angesprochen.
Ich sehe den nicht an der Seitenlinie rumtanzen. Also…
Wehe, also er coacht schon, aber…
Also, ich vergleiche jetzt, ich war wieder aus Palabona-Sicht mit Brüder auf, Baumgart, Quasniok Typen, die an der Seitenlinie mitpumpen, die das Team mit nach vorne peitschen. Ich glaube… Weiß ich nicht, ob ein Räser und Co. mit solchen Typen umgehen können, keine Ahnung, dafür kenne ich sie zu.
Man hatte auch da gefühlt jetzt alle Trainertypen durch.
Ja, gut, bei 4L finde ich es tatsächlich schade, dass man dem nicht mehr Zeit gegeben hat, da die anderen Trainertypen der letzten Jahre habe ich auch nicht so wirklich verstanden. Den schätze ich immer noch als ein großes Trainertalent ein. Ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen verbrannt durch die Nummer. Mal gucken, wo der nochmal unterkommt, aber weiß ich nicht. Für mich passt dieser Typus-Trainer nicht zu dem, was Hertha machen möchte. Wenn sie überhaupt genau wissen, was sie machen möchten. Das ist natürlich ein Punkt, den du noch viel besser gerade beschrieben hast. Da will ich glaube ich der eine das, der nächste das und dann wollen sie es unterschiedlich erreichen und das ist immer ganz, ganz, ganz schwer.
Hertha muss eine neue Kultur entwickeln. Da ist Peter Görlich jetzt an oberste Stelle gefragt. Und ich glaube, an dem Punkt können wir diesen Schwerpunkt Hertha dann auch zumachen und ich kann übergehen in das Outro. Denn wir haben diese Sendung jetzt geschafft, würde ich behaupten. Ich bin damit auch sehr zufrieden. Es hat großen Spaß gemacht. Ein, zwei Teams mussten wir so ein bisschen skippen, aber es ist nun mal so. Ansonsten Kevin, Matthias, vielen lieben Dank für eure Zeit. Es hat großen Spaß gemacht und ich hoffe, dass wir vielleicht ja sogar in der Konstellation uns irgendwann wieder haben. Ansonsten mit Eva, einzeln. Es wird toll. Bis dahin macht es gut. Und die Begrüße an alle HörerInnen. Unterstützt den Rasenfunk-Supporters-Club und schreibt gerne ins Forum, wie es euch gefallen hat. Ciao!
Danke, tschüss!
Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.